the conservative leadership contenders
got a reminder of the scale of the
economic challenge awaiting one of them
today we know inflation is hitting
business and households but rising
prices affect the public finances too
and in june they pushed interest
payments on government debt to a record
19.4 billion pounds and that's not
because of rising interest rates but
because some uk debt repayments seen
here in light blue are linked to the
retail price index of inflation that's
currently
11.8 percent and it helped push
government borrowing in june to almost
23 billion pounds and that's the second
highest june figure ever behind only the
kovid peak way back in june 2020. now
risky sunak and liz trust have set out
contrasting if limited visions for the
economy and we know sunax plans because
their government policy they include a
1.25
national insurance rise imposed in april
worth 13 billion pounds and a planned
increase in corporation tax from 19 to
25 that'll raise 17 billion pounds liz
trust says she'll cancel both of these a
tax cut worth 30 billion pounds so let's
have a look at what that would mean for
the public finances government is
forecast to spend 1 100 billion 1.1
trillion pounds next year but taxes will
raise 50 billion pounds less than that a
deficit that has to be covered somehow
now let's knock off liz truss's 30
billion pound tax cut she says it will
help stimulate growth and pay for itself
but if she's wrong there are two options
the first is that the deficit grows
increasing borrowing to 80 billion
pounds the second is that government
spending has to fall and on that liz
trust has been silent but she has
claimed that her tax cuts will actually
reduce inflation which is not an
orthodox economic view
i think more responsibility rests with
the bank of england and on the monetary
policy side
than with the future prime minister and
the fiscal side
however i do also find it difficult to
make an argument that essentially
pumping money into the economy is going
to be deflationary
what the candidates do agree on is that
the economy faces huge challenges led by
inflation but so far they're fighting on
a much narrower front